how did this film come to d-man what did
the idea come from just just take me
back to the to the point one okay first
let me let me just preface all of that
by saying Barry Jenkins okay not bad
thank you to Katina Fisher and Dena and
Randy and everybody at the Academy for
putting on this event we appreciate that
I had I had come to Hollywood make this
as brief as possible I had come to
Hollywood on a job working for the
Hughes brothers and I arrived and got
fired immediately and I had early this
you know if you know that you any way I
I had went before I had moved to Los
Angeles I had sort of been a kind of
amateur poet and been involved in a
world that was very similar to what
depicted in the movie NIDA sort of kept
of the world of that in the back of my
mind is something that might be
interesting but I never really thought
that I could do anything with it I came
here to write a different kind of movie
and I had met Elena at chigorin Elena
Perez now but at the time Selena had you
going she's out here somewhere
where are you Lena okay there's Elena at
Sugoi infrared okay who was an executive
at new line at the time and so we had
had a we knew each other sort of around
and she said what are you doing I had
written a movie I got fired off this job
or whatever and I said well I have this
idea
so it's you know she's a photographer
and he's a poet and I don't know they
fall in love or something like that and
blah blah blah she was like right that
literally like that and I was like
really I don't think that's something I
could get really through Hollywood
that's you know I was came here to write
the French Connection that's right
she was like no no no I want to see that
movie right that so I wrote it and she
helped me and then Nick Wechsler where's
Nick Wechsler right there that guy yo
big yo Nick Wechsler that guy is a
Hollywood legend yes I said that guy has
produced every major director of the
last 25 years and little old me and so
we wouldn't be here without Nick and
Hellena and some other folks as well
Julia's on the pound she'll speak as
well so anyway so Nick had gotten ahold
of the script said he want to produce it
and then we set it up at new line and
Hellena got it through the system and we
set it up in they made my deal in June
and we were greenlit and shooting in
January right anybody who works in show
business knows that's insane I thought
it was like Nick was later homeless you
don't understand it doesn't really work
like this now it's my first movie and
I'm like Nick what are you talking about
it's me like I came here with a dream
and that's how it goes
he's like you don't understand it
doesn't it doesn't work like this and it
and after 20 years it doesn't but it did
that time so that's the there you go
that's my long story about how we got
started and in six months we were making
the movie